ok on est parti sur de mauvaises bases
et je vais me mettre dans la poche où
j'habite ça m'amuse pas bon ça marche et
s'éclate on s'est pas passé répondu tout
comprendre
j'aurais peut-être dû le laisser gagner
savoir pour poser boule et bill c'était
quand même l'occasion en tant que
scénariste et réalisateur de mener le
projet de a à z et donnait vraiment
notre vision de ce qu'on estime être une
bonne adaptation de bd il ya jamais
d'histoire développer dans boule et bill
je crois car un album on a eu 2 mais
sinon c'est tout le temps à une planche
un gag est en fait faut pas vivre ça
comme un énorme handicap en se disant
comment on va faire pour relier tous ces
gars contre non ce qui est vachement
rigolo avec dans cette configuration là
c'est qu'on est totalement libre
d'inventer une histoire puisqu'il n'y a
aucune qui soit préexistantes quoi moi
je conseille l'intelligence du scénario
c'est que ce n'est pas une adaptation de
la bd on va pas prendre sont des
vignettes la bd non c'est pas une
adaptation c'est parce que la génèse
comment c'est arrivé on voulait que les
personnages vraiment ils soient faits de
chair quoi et on voulait pas sacrifier
ça pour quelques
bon gag aux gros gags en fait t'as rien
de mieux à faire que de cliquer du
voisin y a pas besoin d'une ressemblance
exactement ressembler à des dessins
c'est assez compliqué d'ailleurs c'est
un petit cocker alors que le chien de
boule et bill
il est symbolisé un peu bon bah c'est
pareil on va dire que la mère le père
delà même quand il les désigne les
symbolise très agréable d'avoir la
notoriété d'une bd qui est dans le
patrimoine
quand même et en même temps d'avoir la
certitude d'avoir fourni quelque chose
de personnel
c'est pas comme ça qu'on tient un chien
et c'est moi ça tu m'a drôlement bien
réussi j'ai la taille aussi fier non
voilà c'est la gaffe